the libs are now focusing their
rhetorical skill on persuading us all of
the moral good of orgies the latest
issue of New York Magazine takes up the
challenge as the magazine explains quote
the new issue explores the world of
ethical non- monogamy brief digression
if you have to describe something
specifically as ethical it probably is
not ethical non- monogamy is a
contradiction in terms it is like a
vegan lion or elderly babies New York
Magazine goes on quote the package
includes a feature by Allison Davis on
one specific polycule and offers poly
curious readers an in-depth guide to
opening up their relationships an
in-depth guide the libs are not just
detailing the degenerate behavior of
weirdos they are actively trying to get
you to try it too